[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen oder mittag ich
habe keine ahnung was hier gerade ist
erwartet uns auf jeden fall mit unserer
kleinen auch nicht allzu süßen minecraft
werde denn wir befinden uns hier noch
immer in der hölle hier oben befindet
sich gold und quarz und gemerkt auch
schon freunde ich bin so ein bisschen
nervös denn ich weiß nicht so richtig
wie wir herauskommen sollen wir haben ja
hier die konstruktion gebaut mit dem
zaun so dass das feuer an ihm
vorübergeht auf unser portal
ich vertraue dem ganzen noch nicht so
richtig von daher habe ich mich auch ein
bisschen schlau gemacht in den
kommentaren
und da wurde mir geschrieben luca die
einzige möglichkeit da rauszukommen ist
wirklich entweder du kraft ist dir ein
feuerzeug das funktioniert nicht denn
ich habe kein reisen
ich weiß dass ich dem fenster und ich
benötige den würde ich hier unten vor
dem kieswerk kriegen die sache ist nicht
so sind diese haben
ich habe deren android blog rat abgebaut
da ich ja gar nicht drüber nachgedacht
dass ihr das nicht feiern dieser gold
blog.de nicht abgebaut habe ist nämlich
die einzige möglichkeit wie ich auf dem
neckar wieder entfliehen kann
denn durch diesen gold blog bekomme ich
neuen goldbarren und mit diesem neuen
goldbarren kann ich versuchen mit denen
komme hier brennt wirklich goldings ich
kann versuchen mit den komischen zombies
hier zu traden und das wie einer von
denen eventuell eine feuerkugel gibt da
brauche ich eine ganz ganz große menge
glück denn das ist wohl irgendwie
relativ selten und diese feuerkugel kann
ich dann auch meine portal schmeißen so
dass ich dann zurück in meine oberwelt
komme und dann müssen wir heute auch in
das schaf ist ja der letzten folge
leider verstorben
von daher hab ich mir überlegt wir bauen
dem schaf eine extreme geiles grab und
ich möchte auch eine kleine rede halten
ich hab ihm gesagt habe ich nicht
sid
ich werde mir jetzt einfach mal noch
einen goldbarren hierzu ja ich kann mir
dann was vernünftiges gegeben hat denn
jetzt der kleine genommen oder der gros
der kleine der gibt mir nie was der
läuft jetzt einfach guckt euch doch
einfach weg nur der große hier du sollst
dir eine perfekt er hat auf jeden fall
groß jetzt kommt die studie eine
feuerkugel bitte sag ich auch nicht nein
ich bleibe euch eine kurze time nun
zeigen wie ich versuche hier irgendwie
zu treiben
[Musik]
oh mein gott
endlich ich habe eine feuerkugel oh mein
gott ich bin gerade 20 minuten oder
länger keine ahnung wie herum gelaufen
ich bin noch mal in meine festung hier
eingegangen weil dort noch ein gold
block war denn ich kann diese kleinen
goldnuggets die ich hatte konnte ich ja
nicht zu goldbarren machen da ich ja
keine werkbank mit dabei hatte war ich
ja kein gold habe weil ich hab kein holz
habe von daher bin ich gerade extrem
happy dass es jetzt endlich geklappt hat
ich muss jetzt nur noch irgendwie nach
hause finden und hier sieht irgendwie
ziemlich falsch aus hier vorne sind wir
jetzt unendlich wieder an unserem portal
angekommen und wir können jetzt auch
endlich diese komische konzepte auf dem
tisch lag ist eine klimaanlage gerade
angegangen das kann doch jetzt nicht
wahr sein dass ich hier unfassbar langen
der kompletten hölle unterwegs war ich
habe trading die sonst ich hab wurf
tränke der feuer resistenz bekomme ich
spektral feile bekommen die haben
unfassbar viel leder und netter ziegel
zugeworfen ist eine feuerkugel jetzt
freue ich mich hier so extrem und jetzt
er ist der dinge angegangen ich meinen
scheiße blöden seoul
wenn das jetzt funktionieren fresse ich
einen besen bis 25 minuten in der
lebenszeit die gerade verschwendet und
das sind wir
die ränder manager in der hölle kommen
dann bleib hier also meine lieben
freunde
[Musik]
warum haben wir hier so viele ende
werden sind ändern
die neuen trieb
[Musik]
wir haben hier ein wir haben dort ein
wir haben dort an
[Musik]
ich habe mir das nicht
ja ich bin angekommen ich habe also ich
wollte zoomen und ist den leuten da eine
ewigkeit später so die wichtigsten
sachen habe ich gesichert ich weiß jetzt
gerade nicht wo der ender wende ist
allerdings ist er hier auf jeden fall
nicht mehr am start wir müssen uns nun
allerdings sind
[Musik]
ich höre auf jeden fall von ihnen
element ich hab ein bisschen schiss
[Musik]
er ist nicht böse ich kann euch schon
mal ganz kurz sagen was das ziel für die
heutige episode ist denn ich möchte dort
hinten
dorthin möchte ich das grab für das
scharf drauf setzen da wurde nämlich und
in die kommentare geschrieben luca die
werden wir nur einfach einen schafskopf
dort hinten hin baust und dann hab ich
mir gedacht ja irgendwie passt das nicht
so richtig so pixel art mäßig jetzt
irgendwie so ein schafskopf dahin zu
setzen allerdings habe ich mir dann
gedacht das schaf war auch so ein
bisschen speziell gerade auch mit dem
ganzen farbwechsel da war sicher über
dieses namensschild namens job gemacht
habe von einer dachte ich mir dass es
vielleicht doch ganz gut passt deswegen
müssen wir auf jeden fall die oberen
drei sandschichten hier erst mal ganz
kurz abtragen und dann brauchen wir auf
jeden fall auch eine menge ton ich habe
vorhin schon gesehen dass wir vorne ein
bisschen was haben allerdings wird das
auf gar keinen fall ausreichen und wir
müssen dafür auf jeden fall noch mal
rüber fahren in unseren sund
beziehungsweise haben wir hier vorne
vielleicht doch noch irgendwo was das
sieht allerdings ein bisschen schlecht
aus die sonne geht da vorne auch schon
wieder unter deswegen würde ich sagen
schwimmen mit kurz rüber
die im schlaf von euch ein ganz großer
teil des wie ich in den sumpf are
[Musik]
ich wollte euch eigentlich detail bleibt
einblenden wie schlafen gehe und wie ich
jetzt darüber fahrer allerdings ist das
gerade wirklich sehr beängstigend
[Musik]
und da sind wir hier vorne auch schon in
unserem sumpf angekommen und sehen auch
schon direkt hier vorne den ersten ton
den wir komplett benötigen wir benötigen
diesen ton nämlich um uns daraus keramik
zu machen mit der mit der sache keramik
habe ich noch gar nicht
in diesem projekt mannschaft mit lucca
so richtig gearbeitet ist allerdings
auch nicht weiter schlimm haben dafür
immer beton genutzt allerdings ist für
dieses schafkopf pixel art ding was ich
mir vorstelle keramik auf jeden fall
besser geeignet und da gibt es bessere
farben für gerade magenta und violett
die sache ist wo wir jetzt hier gerade
schon unserem sumpf befinden und dich ja
darauf hin dass sich einige kommentare
gelesen habe in denen unter den folgen
minecraft mit luca hier um leute
geschrieben haben
luke aden kannst mit ton in sümpfen
extrem viel diamanten bekommen da muss
man sich nämlich einfach irgendwie in
der mitte untergraben und dann sechs
blöcke in richtung süd achse gehen bei
den f3 koordinaten es klingt sehr
kompliziert ist es allerdings eigentlich
gar nicht die sache ist allerdings dass
er wisse dass sich die koordinaten
eigentlich nicht benutzen möchte also
ich möchte eigentlich nicht auf 3
drücken oder irgendwie sehen okay dass
meine koordinaten wenn ich jetzt nach
hause wie mache ich dies wenn ich das
mache ich das ich habe mir gerade im
netz auch einfach irgendwie fahrzeug
geben können oder sogar dem command das
möchte ich nicht das macht für mich das
ganz projekt ein bisschen kaputt
deswegen möchte ich auch diese methode
mit den diamanten nicht anwenden und ich
finde es generell ein bisschen cooler
wenn man einfach in höhlen geht und dort
hat irgendwie diamanten findet
allerdings dass kurze einfach alles was
wir hier schon gebaut haben ich bin so
stolz auf dieses projekt nach so freunde
ihr seht schon ich habe unsere inventar
einige blöcke die ich vorher noch nicht
hatte das ist nämlich weiße keramik
schwarzer beton magenta keramik violette
keramik und 59 weiße wolle dafür hätte
ich am besten ich auch weißem beton oder
weiße keramik nehmen müssen so dass das
ganze halt einfach ziemlich
zusammengehören und aussieht wollen sie
gegen die nicht so geil aus wenn man die
verbraucht das hatte ich irgendwie
cooler in erinnerung
die sache ist allerdings dass ich mit
wolle bauen möchte da das schaut ja auch
aus weiter bestand und ich
dementsprechend mir gedacht habe das
passt ganz gut
die sache ist jetzt dass wir erst mal
hier sondern 1 2 3 4 5 6
8 ist es denn so hoch ich weiß es gab
gar nicht wir bauen auf jeden fall
erstmal seinen rahmen hier vorne rum das
ist nämlich der kopf von dem schaf und
das gleiche machen wir dann auch noch
mal auf der anderen seite da gehen wir
nämlich jetzt noch mal kurz dieser
anzahl an blöcken hier hoch sagt da
kriegen wir kurz müssen schaden 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 das passt auf jeden fall die
sonne geht davon unterdessen habe ich
mache eine reise partie ganz kurz
mitgenommen auch wenn ich direkt hier
vorne lebe und die haben das noch nie
gesehen alles nur unser trauer insel
wir fordern die widderter insel unser
baumhaus und alles die zauberinsel das
portal und erleuchtung ich habe auch
erst überlegt ob ich das schaffst pixel
artie vorne hin setzte dann können wir
nämlich von der arbeit ich immer ganz
gut aussehen
die sache ist allerdings dass sie nicht
der platz ist den ich dafür brauche das
soll ja acht blöcke breit werden jetzt
nehmen wir auf jeden fall unsere weiße
keramik und setzten die hier vorne so
hin nämlich 123456 in die mitte kommen
dann auch nochmal 2
dann hab ich mir vergessen zu machen
allerdings ganz kurz den rest der schon
mal fertig bauen dann kommt nämlich in
form noch weiße wolle hin und hier haben
wir dann auf der reiteralm magenta
keramik und darüber violette kehre habe
ich jetzt gehe ich mal ganz kurz
schlafen und muss dann auch gleich noch
mal leider kurz zurück um ihr die
restliche weiße keramik machen denn die
habe ich leider vergessen ich muss nicht
dass wir so viel davon benötigen von
daher halte ich mit dem boot jetzt noch
mal ganz kurz vorne direkt hier eben an
unserem häuschen und nicht hinten an
unserem bootssteg so dass ich mich
einmal ganz kurz findet meine 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 und keramik rausnehmen und ein
farbstoff denn erst dann bekomme ich die
weiße keramik alles aber darum legen
weiße keramik jetzt wieder ab ins
brötchen tür natürlich nicht vergessen
zu machen und was ich auch noch sagen
muss meine lieben freunde ich werde
nicht nur dass schaaf da jetzt einfach
hin bauen und dann sagen okay das ist
dann das grab für das schaf sondern ich
habe auch ein kleines gedicht
vorbereitet das möchte ich gleich im
alltag unserer kirchen trauer insel
situation halten zuvor platzieren wir
allerdings an den fehlenden stellen eben
noch die weiße keramik das ist
allerdings falsch denn die kommt hier
nicht in ihr kommt nämlich weiße wolle
hinzu
zack und hier kommt die weiße keramik in
davos habe ich mich noch mehr
bin ich denn völlig lost ich habe das
komplett falsch aufgeschrieben so die
letztliche 8
die ich noch benötigt hat platziere ich
jetzt hier vorne dran und hier auch
nochmal zwei weise wolle das jetzt jetzt
auf jeden fall der schafskopf ich glaube
wenn man direkt davor steht bei uns
nicht so gut erkennen von der entfernung
geht es auf jeden fall noch mal deutlich
besser klar was ich jetzt machen wollte
war dass ich mir eben kurz mit den
ganzen slams die wir ja irgendwann
letztens in unserer höhle in unserer
mine unten bekommen haben weil er die
ganzen steins pons sind mit denen wollte
ich mir jetzt einige weinen machen und
dann wollte ich alle mitglieder von
meiner insel also dementsprechend ja
nicht mehr das schaf leider sondern das
schwein die kuh und auch vale wollte ich
mitnehmen auf die trauminsel in die
kirche so dass alle in dem altar in der
kirche mit dabei sind wenn ich die rede
halte von daher laufe ich mal eben kurz
darüber zu unserer strandhaus villa denn
hier vorne haben wir auf jeden fall noch
einige fäden die ich nun so anordnen
können ein zweiter dass ich mir zwei
leinen machen kann sagt jetzt habe ich
mir viel leiden gemacht aber ist auch
egal
und damit werde ich jetzt die ganzen
tiere mit rüber nehmen ich weiß nicht ob
ich gerade dumm bin aber kann ich jetzt
nicht theoretisch den ändern wenn ihr
kind einfach schlagen weil er ja in
meinem besitz und er ist tot
hat mir aber keiner als fett mainka
wieder weg mir jetzt keine ender perle
gegeben naja egal also wir konzentrieren
uns auf jeden fall auf unser ziel
dementsprechend werde ich jetzt ganz
ganz nah diese leider nehmen die gruber
mitnehmen und das schwein auch das ding
zum bluthochdruck
[Musik]
das ist nicht wahr
das kann doch nicht sein
ich nehme die leine ziel ist hier hoch
dass die kuh kann ganz easy einfach hier
hoch springen
ich drehe mich um gucke hey wieso kommt
es nicht hoch und sie stimmt
sorry aber da sehe ich jetzt keine
schuld gerade bei mir
wir können doch nicht jetzt rüber fahren
zur insel hier vorne zur kirche und ich
halte mein gedicht was ich
aufgeschrieben haben vorhin vor der
aufnahme und die crews auch droht ich
habe die kuh mit mit reingenommen mein
gedicht
[Musik]
wisst ihr was wir machen ich beende an
der stelle jetzt mein heutiges video
meiner lieben freunde ich werde jetzt
noch mal ein neues gedicht schreiben
auch für die kuh und die nächste folge
die übermorgen um 20 uhr online gehen
wird am samstagabend die große trauer
folge sein ich werde auch der kuh hier
vorne auf unserem sand situations berg
dahinten wo man den schafskopf da oben
auch schon eingeblendet seht daneben
werde ich der kuh ein pixel hat bauen
sodass wir sehen okay das schaf und die
kuh die wurden vernünftig von uns
verabschiedet dann haben wir hier vorne
das schaf wir haben hier vorne den kopf
und dann werde ich noch ein zweites
gedicht schreiben was ich euch dann in
der nächsten folge vortragen werde
hinten in der kirche von daher meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen
lassen einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da es kann nicht ob ich das sagen
kann weil jetzt ja wieder mit einem
traurigen ende das ganze beendet wird
allerdings wie bereits gesagt lasst
keinen daumen hoch und ein video hier da
abonniert meinen kanal und klickt auf
die glocke wenn die erste folge
übermorgen um 20 nicht verpassen wollt
schreibt mir gerne und in die kommentare
wie wir jetzt den verlust ausgleichen
können und der coo und von dem schaf
dann sehen wir uns für morgen wieder
was gut für sie
[Applaus]
[Musik]